[Music]
thank you
all right so the Latin name is
and it's free free-tailed beds
[Music]
only chance to survive for this colony
to transport it to our batch
habilitation Center and uh because the
other option is just through through
them away to the harsh winter and they
just die in an hour
[Music]
thank you
we actually find more than 4 000 beds in
parking
we have to keep these bats in some
artificial conditions so
like artificial hibernation actually we
have one big room with uh
eight eight uh refrigerators how it
worked it actually it's a refrigerator
with full of these bags with hibernating
beds and they put they like sitting
together forming some uh aggregation
and uh just sleep
it's fighting from the windows of our
office uh we're here not only a
challenge but also we heard the machine
gun fire it means that somewhere on the
margin of the city it was already
fighting and we hear it we saw the smoke
of heated Russian towns
[Music]
you are very hard to working with our
beds to put them in this cage
and to give them the chance to to fly
away
foreign